this week if you want to move past
endless space exploration I encourage
you to consider the ps4 experimental
platformer found the developers have
said this game is heavily narrative
driven but it also has some heat when it
comes to platforming you're in the mind
of a woman who's traveling into the
memories of her childhood she travels
like I do with style actually it's more
like interpretive dance but it's got
quite an extraordinary sense of visual
style which is accompanied by a very
beautiful soundtrack of chill
electro-acoustic music that'll melt away
your worries this isn't for everyone but
it's certainly on my radar so consider
bound on ps4 on the 16th hey remember
when grow home released out of nowhere
and became the best ubisoft game that no
one ever knew they wanted well it's back
and it's going to new heights with grow
up our beloved robot friend bud is back
and he's dealing with mom how relatable
pieces of mom are scattered all around a
beautiful planet covered in various
species for you to explore and its buds
job to get those parts and deliver them
to the moon with a wide smile that
really only bud is capable of there's
just no way I'm missing out on this and
for a game that's coming out on ps4 and
xbox one and pc no one's out of the loop
aim for the moon on the 16th but if you
ever just wanted to rule over everyone
you're finally going to get a game that
strokes your ego with Oh close you bring
the pain by creating an angry and
violent mob that kills anything and
everything in your path don't forget to
feed them and enrage them from time to
time to get to the Golden Gods and take
them down a notch behold the power of
violence also confirming my mother's
theory that the masses are asses but hey
they follow you so you can change the
world for better or for worse this is
out on the 18th on computers of all
varieties
we say easy to play difficult to master
a lot on gamespot but a really really
good example of that is the super clean
super streamlined in versus it reels you
in with promises of clean lines and
simple gameplay and then it adds
multiple players both online and local
with a myriad of various arenas that
change up the gameplay constantly and
add mirrored images to throw your brain
for a loop and what the hell is that
read now and where did that get there
this game totally surprises you and
keeps changing it up so you never feel
like you totally get it mastering the
controls is fun and it's constantly
changing so you get that sweet
multiplayer battle experience in versus
challenges you on the 16th and that's
all I got for you this week do you
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings sometimes they change
up a little bit and I'll see you guys
again next week